the British general election is ending
exactly as it began the air is thick
with allegations that the Russians are
coming in the beginning believer or not
it was labour alleging that Boris
Johnson and the Conservatives were in
the pay of the Russians it's ending with
the allegation now coming from every
spook source in the land that somehow
the Russians managed to give Jeremy
Corbyn details of Britain's trade
discussions with Donald Trump's
administration for the post brexit era
neither allegation of course is true but
it's a measure of just how magnificent a
figure this Vladimir Putin has turned
out to be
he picked the last American president
and is trying to pick the next one he
rigged the brexit referendum he created
a national movement in Catalonia I even
tried to break Scotland off from London
all the while running rather an
important and large country at the same
time there is no end to the talents of
the magician in the Kremlin all of the
foregoing was of course a joke and so
are these allegations the truth is the
election is ending as it begun with the
Tories very considerably ahead in the
Sunday papers in the largest poll you
might say therefore the most
authoritative pull the Conservatives are
15 points clear and labour is heading
for a 1983 style heavy defeat at which
point its leader Jeremy Corbyn
presumably walks to be replaced by the
man that's been operating him for months
the Shadow Chancellor John MacDonald but
if JC were to win it would be quite
frankly a miracle and
be able to walk across the Thames ascend
the wall into the Parliament House as
Britain's first ever socialist
anti-imperialist Prime Minister it would
be extraordinary that unentitled
off like Boris Johnson could become a
majority prime minister the wisest fool
in Christendom overeducated
but under wise labour will have lost of
their own doing Labour's u-turn on the
bricks issue has lost them and
absolutely certain dozens maybe scores
of seats behind what used to be called
the red wall in the Midlands in the
northwest in the northeast and in South
Wales amongst working-class people in
Britain there's a feeling I'm here to
tell you for our experience every single
day that Labour know neither looks
sounds or is like them it's a kind of
culture war issue working-class people
do not believe that the metropolitan
middle class University educated Labor
Party of today has anything very much to
do with them general election 2019 will
also mark mark my words the beginning of
the end of the so-called mainstream
British media I see no justification for
paying to be lied to and the British
people have been lied to in a deluge in
a tsunami of lies and distortion about
the personalities and the policies and
the general approach of both of these
main parties and my final ward is this
those of you who were up in arms going
to a High Court to stop the prorogation
of the last Parliament will be begging
for the next Parliament to be provoked
because trust me on this another five
years of
majority Tory government led by Boris
Johnson is not going to be nice to look
at